foreign
[Music]
thanks for coming to my talk my name is
June I'm a PhD student in linguistics at
the University of Pennsylvania and today
I'll be talking about ggplot internals
and my package Gigi Trace
so I suspect that most of us here are
already pretty familiar with ggplot but
just to get a sense of the room how many
of us has made like a box plot in a
ggplot before
all right that's like literally everyone
cool and I make them all the time too
it's like one of the first plots I make
when I get results back from an
experiment so let's say like a
behavioral data of like button presses
so each row is a response from a
participant and there's columns for
experiment condition and response time
so I can write a short code where I pass
my data to ggplot map condition to X and
fill and response times to Y and add a g
on box plot layer pretty straightforward
that gives me a box plot so that was
very simple to do in ggplot
um and oftentimes I'll have participants
who are behaving let's say more
interestingly than others and I care
about identifying them for a lot of
reasons so I might also want to annotate
the cutoff value for extreme outliers
like this and of course I should
calculate myself if I like really care
and if it's really important but I'm
just doing a quick exploratory analysis
and I already know how to tell ggplot to
calculate this for me so labeling that
same value should be a trivial task
right
except it turns out this is kind of
tricky because what we're trying to do
is do something like a box plot layer
except divert its normal course of
action under the hood
so our new layer should calculate the
same variable as our first layer but
then instead of using boxes and whiskers
to draw all of them it should label just
one of them and when it comes to these
situations where the user wants to
intervene in the process power layer
comes to life there is good news and bad
news the good news is thanks to recent
developers we can write a layer that
does all this all inside and all on the
fly all inside a geom label layer so
that's great but the bad news is this is
incomprehensible like this is not your
typical ggplot code so we have strange
functions called inside the AES like
stage and after set and we're using the
stat and data arguments of the geom
label layer which we don't often do so
like this is still like vanilla ggplot
but this kind of code it's very
difficult to reason about because it
requires a mental model of how ggplot
internals work and here's what I mean by
that
so the code for our first layer is easy
because we can get away with thinking
about a layer as just doing one big
thing so like hey Geon box plot here's
all the stuff you need now go do your
thing but we need to revise the simple
model of how layers are built to
understand code like the second layer
which reads more like hey layer you know
that data that I gave you to draw apply
this function to it first and then
proceed as normal with condition map to
X and response times mapped to Y then
after the box plot stat steps in and
transforms the data then use the
computed variable y Max to remap to the
Y aesthetic and do the same for the
label aesthetic and then lastly use the
label GM to draw what you have
that was a mouthful and you get the
point what appeared to be a simple task
of annotating a box plot variable turns
out to require a deep understanding of
what goes on where in the internals and
it's not just because there's more code
that is difficult it's conceptually
difficult because it makes references to
different steps in the internals that we
as users don't get to see and I don't
know about you but I would love to be
able to write code like this so if a
knowledge if it requires the knowledge
of the internals if that's what it takes
then maybe ggplot internals are just for
developers anymore and so that's what I
want to talk about today I would like to
propose a model of ggplot internals for
users one that's immediately practical
to users just wanting to get better at
ggplot but also one that offers an
accessible starting point for aspiring
developers who want to extend ggplot
so here's my proposal in a nutshell why
don't we just pretend that Gigi plot
internals is a one big data wrangling
function because it kind of is and to do
that I have developed my package GG
Trace which I'll be showcasing today
so here is the outline for the rest of
my talk so first I'll introduce this
reframing of ggplot internals as data
wrangling which will also provide
context and motivation for my package GG
trace and then I'll demonstrate how we
can put this idea into practice using a
simple example using functions from GG
Trace starting with an example of a bar
plot and then returning to our box plot
annotation problem and then building up
the solution from scratch
so our dive into the internals begins
with this factual observation that each
layer of a Gigi plot has an underlying
data frame representation so in other
words layers are just data frames until
they get drawn so we can actually see
this using ggplot's own layer data
function so we pass it our plot and the
index of the layer we want to inspect
and it gives us the data that's
underlying the box plot layer of our
plot and this is the actual data frame
that gets sent off to the quote-unquote
drawing system which is kind of like the
graphical Object Land with like grid
functions and G table functions but for
our purposes we'll just pretend that all
of the internals is a function that just
takes the raw data that we give it which
is the experiment data that we provided
and makes it drawing ready like this and
does this process for every layer in our
plot according to each layer's own
specifications and this doesn't look too
bad right our input was a tidy data and
the output is just another tidy data
where each row represents a box plot and
the columns are Aesthetics that describe
each box plot including the value for
the upper whiskers stored in the Y Max
column and crucially as you might
suspect this process of making a layer's
data drawing ready happens in steps not
all at once so why do we care about that
as users well because again different
pieces of the code that we write also
kicks in in different Steps step by step
to make the layers data more and more
drawing ready so it's literally like
data wrangling happening under the hood
except you don't get to see your data
again after it goes off and off your
hands
you know so kind of like this
so I'm like simplifying things a bit
here but for our purposes as users we
can think of the internals as divided up
or sliced into these four big steps
which I'll call the before start the
before geom the or before start after
stat before geom and after scale and
because they happen in order how a piece
of our code layer code changes the
current state of a data in this pipeline
at one step has consequences for what
kind of code we can write for that data
in another step so so far so good
now we just need to see what the data
actually looks like at these steps so we
go digging into the internals and we
find that the data passes through these
scary looking things called GGO Proto
methods and not like the kind of d-plier
functions we're familiar with and four
steps that we care about as users those
are also the inputs and outputs of these
GG Proto methods these three to be exact
so in the internals the raw data is
input and the before stock data is the
state of the layer data when it's passed
into the layer GG Proto objects compute
statistic method that the afterstat data
is the output of that same method and
then the before geom data is the input
to this this next method and then the
after scale data is the output of this
other method and then some more stuff
happens and then the data becomes
drawing ready and then it gets sent off
to be drawn so the fact that the
internals are written this way is a big
reason why it's deliberately kept hidden
from us users Gigi Proto is scary and
we're honestly like better off not
knowing anything about them
like this first method here layer
compute statistic it looks like this and
it's like nothing you've seen before
it's like a function but it's composed
of two other functions and it has this
argument called self which is like a big
thing from object-oriented programming
that's like very intimidating to me as
an R user and maybe to you too although
if you are interested in op you're in
the right place just like 40 minutes
earlier
and this method is actually also like a
nested call to several other GG Proto
methods and they're like all written in
like base R and it can get very
overwhelming and then recently they also
added in like vectors integration and
CLI integration and it's a lot like okay
I wanted to know what goes on in the
internals but not like this this is
developer territory
right all I care about is just seeing
the data like give me the data frame so
that I can anticipate what my code will
do in the middle of the pipeline when it
kicks in and so that's the motivation
behind Gigi trees so Gigi Trace is a
package that allows us the users to drop
inside like parachute down this internal
pipeline at any point we want and
intercept the data at that step and
interact with it using the kind of data
wrangling tools that we're already
familiar with
so GG Trace comes with a family of
workflow functions in the form of GG
Trace action value which all take three
arguments the ggplot object the GG Proto
method and when to interact with that
method
so this talk will showcase just two
functions from the inspect workflow GG
Trace inspect args and GG Trace inspect
return which lets us take a snapshot of
a layer's data as it goes in and out of
GG Proto methods
so for example if we want to look at the
state of a layers data in the before
start stage then we can use GG Trace
inspect args to intercept the data that
was passed into layer compute statistic
when it is first called for our plot
which gives us the box plot layers after
stat data and then likewise if we want
to look at the layers after set or sorry
that was the before stat data if we want
to look at the afterstat data we need to
use GG Trace inspect return instead to
intercept the data when it is returned
by that same method which gives us the
box plot layers after sat data
so now that we're equipped with the
tools to peek inside the internals let's
use these inspect functions to walk
through how a layer gets built for the
bar plot step by step and we'll be using
the Penguins data set so if you're not
familiar this is a data set where each
row is a penguin with columns for a
species and build length and so using GM
bar we can visualize the counter
penguins in each species by mapping the
species column to X and fill so like
simple right pretty straightforward
we don't really think about how layers
are built in steps when we write code
like this but once we spell out the
defaults like stat equals count and Y
equals after stat count we see clear
parallels to our more complex box plot
annotation layer which is why I like
this example
so in the internals the bar layers data
starts off as the Penguin's data and
ends up in its drawing ready form and to
see how this all happens we use Gigi
Trace to intercept the data at the four
steps that we care about
so let's look at some data frames we
start by intercepting the data at the
before start stage so we use GG Trace
inspect RS again to pull out the data
argument that was passed into this GG
Proto method which gives us a data frame
that looks like this
so here our initial aesthetic mappings
are reflected in the presence of these
columns named after the actual
Aesthetics like X and fill which is like
basically select and rename and we see
some other things that happen to the
data at this point as well like the axis
numeric and we have these new columns
like panel and group if we pass the
function to the data argument of the
layer this is also the point by which
that would get applied to our data and
but the real significance of the before
stat data is that it validates the
layer's choice of stat so our before
stat data has a column for x and that
satisfies the layers count stat which
requires either unex or Y aesthetic as
we see from the documentation
if we specify both X and Y like this
then the plot fails to build and it
errors specifically at stat count
and so we can set error equals true in
our GG Trace function to debug the
layer's data and here we can see the
reason why it's because both the columns
X and Y are present when this dot goes
in to look at the data
and we if we uh but as long as the stat
has what it needs then it will transform
the data spit it back out for us to see
in the afterstat stage so at this point
we see that the data basically underwent
a group by and summarize so we have one
row for each bar and new variables like
count and prop so the afterstat stage is
significant because it's an opportunity
for us to declare more aesthetic
mappings except we can use variables
from this afterstat data frame
so the fact that we have a column called
count in the afterstat data is what
allows this default mapping of y equals
Aftershock count and that's essentially
just calling mutate y equals count on
the afterstat data and like this isn't
just a metaphor like aesthetic mappings
are literally powered by tidy Evo so the
symbol count is evaluated to the vector
count so you can do things like y equals
count over sum of count which will give
you proportions and have consequences
down the line for the plot and any after
stop mappings that we declare like this
will get applied to the data for us to
see by the time the data reaches the
before geom stage so we see now the data
has that y column present when we
intercept it here and just like in the
before start the before geom step data
the before geoms data validates the
layer's choice of geom so here we have
both X and Y columns present and that
satisfies our layers gr which is G on
bar and it requires both X and Y
Aesthetics
if we Instead overwrite This default and
not map anything to Y at all by setting
it to null then the stat is satisfied
but the grm down the line is not so it's
G on bar that throws the error and so
conceptually we can see how after scale
mappings are sometimes necessary to make
a stat and a geom work so every layer
has a stat in a genome and they need to
fit together to make a layer come to
life
okay so the next time that we intercept
the data is in the after scale stage so
by this point the non-positional scales
have stepped in to transform Aesthetics
like fill which is now a column of the
actual color values instead of the names
of the penguin species we also see that
the bar geome has stepped in to add
default values for bar related
Aesthetics which are again just columns
like color and size this stage is
significant because just like the
afterstat we can declare more aesthetic
mappings one last time before the data
sent off to be drawn so for example we
have the size column by this point
representing the thickness of the
borders around the bars it's actually
kind of hard to tell the default value
it's small so if we wanted to make it
like five times thicker than it was
originally going to be then like you can
kind of just do that on the Fly grab the
size column when it exists in the after
scale data multiplied by 5 and map it or
assign it back to the size aesthetic and
it's kind of like so aesthetic mappings
are kind of like scheduling a mutate
call on your data for later and this
this can happen on the fly without us
needing to figure out the default value
first and then you know for the database
folks in the room this is also what
allows you to do stuff like make the
outline of the bars a little bit darker
than to fill out the bars and then that
can make your plots look prettier I'll
just leave this here for you if you want
to look at it later
so that concludes our bar plot
walkthrough so to recap a layer's data
becomes drawing ready in steps in the
internals and using the inspect function
from Gigi trees we were able to see what
the data looks like at a certain steps
and crucially how the state of the
layers data can inform what kind of
layer code that we can write and so with
that we Circle back to our box plot
annotation layer
again we have this box plot of response
Times by condition that we made at the
beginning and we'd like to add a layer
labeling the value of the upper whisker
in the second box plot and so applying
what we just learned we can write this
layer in steps just like how the layer
itself is built up in steps so this is
kind of a hard code so we will get stuck
at some point but then I'll show you how
we can use GG Trace to debug our way out
of it
so first thing we start is a high level
description of what we want so every
layer has a stat and a geom so maybe
let's start there we want to use a label
to draw a box plot variable in code that
means geom label with stat equals box
plot or stop box plot with geometrics
label again every layer needs both and
it's actually your choice of syntax
they're the same thing
and next we can specify the data that we
want the layer to plot so we only care
about the second box plot we say filter
for condition as B and let that apply
then we build up the aesthetic mappings
starting with the ones that the stat
needs first because the stat always
receives the data first so we specify
the X and the Y and then additional ones
that the gr might need later like label
which we want to be the same as the Y
max value that the stat computes
and so that gives us a big chunk of code
and we're almost there except for this
error that says geom label is missing a
y aesthetic and like what we do have a y
aesthetic here so like maybe we're not
sure what's wrong but we know how to
debug this the geom is complaining about
a missing aesthetic and so something
must be wrong with the data that it
receives
so then we inspect the before geom
snapshot of the layers data and we do
see that the Y column has been dropped
so it turns out that the box plot stat
consumes the Y column and then returns a
summary across multiple columns like
this so the Y column is missing now
so to resolve that we can use the stage
function again just this is a ggplot
function stage function to map Y at the
start to satisfy the stat and then remap
to y in the afterstat to satisfy the
Geon and then that gets us the layer
that we want because this ensures that
both the before stat data and the before
geom data has a y column present so then
that's what finally gets the layer
working
so that concludes cracking open ggplot
internals or Gigi trees again GG Trace
is helpful it helps us learn the
internals as users by exploiting the
fact that a lot of the internals is just
manipulating data frames and by
reframing the internals in the familiar
data wrangling functional programming
terms that we're all familiar with we
arrive at a conceptual understanding of
how the internals work so this lets us
write more powerful ggplot code as users
while still mostly abstracting away from
the scary implementational details like
GG Proto and base our functions but if
you are interested in that GG Trace has
other workflow functions that you can
use so just really quickly there's
function from the capture workflow like
GG Trace capture FN which essentially
records the behavior of a GG Proto
method when it executes and then you can
kind of have it as a standalone function
you have functions from the hijack
workflow which kind of lets you pass or
make GG Proto methods return arbitrary
values and so you can kind of try to
hack the internals and uh see what you
can come up with and yeah that's it GG
traces on GitHub uh here's some links to
other materials and I'd love to hear
your feedback
[Applause]
[Music]